well hughes over plays and he just gets  caught with his hand in the cookie jar  smart played by the dayton flyers  understanding getting huge out level  teams  in the paint i mean he's emerged this  year he needs to continue  speaking of emerging great balance  set both feet  oh the follow from topping my goodness  to pick up the intensity on defense  it'll be tommy with a steal he's going  to take it all the way  up and under with the layup  not only has done it on the offensive  end but he's also  the stop blocker the very chance to  extend the lead but  knocks it away and gets the steal here  comes crusher  and the alley is playing there's no  defense for that play  46-20 to win it's 75-64.  [Applause]  they'd have to do that again tonight  with another block out of bounds  [Applause]